okay cornbread okay cornbread this is my
grandmother's recipe so this is a recipe
but we're going to pretend that there's
just little pinches and a little this
little bit of this and a little bit of
that pinches of what what goes in
what so here goes here are our dry
ingredients we got flour
we got white cornmeal over there i see
it i'm sure there's a little pinch of
salt i see salt and then we got a little
pinch of um
baking soda and baking powder both both
yes i like yeah
okay now in here we got our little bit
of buttermilk which i think about a cup
one egg some oil and i think that's it
that's in here so we're just gonna whisk
that up again it doesn't have to be
perfect we just want that egg yolk to
not be whole okay so we're going to take
this uh-huh and we're going to very
slowly while we whisk uh-huh pour it in
just a little bit you good yeah this
time
yeah i uh-huh so keep whisking while you
do while you're poor pour and whisk here
let me hold the bowl for you thank you
yeah you guys
now give it a there you go
get it drew there we go
perfect that's perfect so we pour it in
now this is where we use this because
we're going to need it and we just give
it a little pour
right again
ooh that looks good right yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and it's
so simple for sure it's such a like i
feel like a good
you know like not ancient because we're
not ancient
where's the oh right here
there you go okay i'm gonna put mine
next to yours
two little corn breads
and a nice little oven
and then ideally
[Applause]
and honored to spend an afternoon with
you thank you so much thanks for coming
on this show it's a dream it's a dream
give my best to your very kind-giving
husband
i will thank you
ryan in the end game new episodes on nbc
every monday at 10 pm 9 central episodes
are also available the next day on
peacock hulu and the nbc app
[Music]